Joe Biden's bad week just got worse as
Democrats call him racist and the
mainstream media but I repeat myself
accuse him of corruption very bad then a
black NFL star pushes back at Democrats
on yesterday's reparations hearings on
Capitol Hill finally the mailbag I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
absolutely brutal week for Joe Biden
tough times for him on Tuesday actually
I didn't even want to cover this story
at first because I thought it was people
making something out of nothing
I now realize this story of what Joe
Biden said how people are reacting to it
actually does tell you about a major
issue that the Democrats are grappling
with so what did he say he was at a
fundraiser at the Carlyle in New York
City on Tuesday night and Joe Biden
cited his ability to work with two
segregationist Democrat senators as
evidence that you can be civil even with
people that you disagree with and that's
how you can come together and get
something accomplished for the country
so he was referring to the
segregationist senators James O Eastland
of Mississippi and Herman Talmadge of
Georgia and he he in typical Joe Biden
awkward old-timey joke way he came in
and he said you know they never called
me boy like but they called me son they
never called me boy like racists will
call black men boys they called me son
cuz they were of this older school and I
disagreed with them but we came together
and work together and this story is
being twisted not really so much by the
right but but certainly by the left and
by fellow Democrats as portraying Joe
Biden in this bigoted light Joe Biden is
somehow secret racist that we didn't
know about there's really no evidence of
that
he's certainly made racially awkward and
insensitive and offensive comments he
said about Barack Obama when they were
running in 2008 he said that Barack
Obama was the first articulate clean a
good-looking black guy that ever ran for
office and so that was a story book I
mean he said things that are a little
awkward but I don't think they're
evidence that he's this racial bigotry
something like that he's just a weird
old guy still this does tell us
something this tells us something very
important about what the Democrats are
debating right now so of course Joe
Biden's Democrat opponents piled on here
Liz Warren said quote I'm not here to
criticize other Democrats but it's never
okay to celebrate segregationists
never
celebrate you see what they're doing Joe
Biden said I worked with segregationists
and I disagreed with them but I was able
to get something done
Liz Warren paints that as celebrating
segregationists same thing here's Kamala
Harris responding to Biden's remarks I
have a great deal of respect for Vice
President Biden he's done very good work
and he has served our country in a very
noble way but to coddle the reputations
of segregationists of people who if they
had their way I would literally not be
standing here as a member of the United
States Senate is I think it's just it's
misinformed and it's wrong he's gonna
have to make that decision but you know
let's be very clear that the Senators
that he is speaking of with such
adoration are individuals who made and
built their reputation on segregation so
this is a very serious matter a duration
he's adoring them there's nothing in Joe
Biden's remarks that he's adoring those
senators or that he's caught he's
coddling those senators when did he
coddle them or as Liz Warren said he's
celebrating them that is totally made up
and that is completely unfair and I hate
to defend Joe Biden but it's that's
ridiculous and you'll you'll listen to
how Kamala Harris phrases this here she
goes I have the most respect for Joe
Biden he's a great guy because she knows
she's not gonna win this race and so
she's trying to suck up to maybe be the
vice president she can't hit Joe too
hard but she's got to take the shot at
him because this is open that you this
is an open and vulnerable moment you
don't run for number two you've got to
run hard the only way you're gonna
become a number two is if you run hard
so okay there they're all taking their
shots and and what did Joe Biden
actually say he's mentioning people that
he disagreed with that he was able to
work with the thing that people keep
forgetting here though including Joe
Biden is the example that he's giving is
not an example of him working across the
aisle with Republicans he's talking
about working with members of his own
party because those two segregationists
like virtually all segregationists were
Democrats they weren't Republicans the
the Democratic Party is the worst party
in the history of the world on race
relations through the party of slavery
the party of Jim Crow there's a party at
the KKK through the party of segregate
and this was true not in the way distant
past this was true in Joe Biden's
lifetime and he was working with them as
members of his own party he hasn't been
able to give a good example of working
across the aisle in maintaining civility
but it's okay because the mainstream
media is doing his work for him Joe and
the mainstream media are pretending that
this is an example of working with
Republicans and on one particularly
egregious MSNBC show this is Casey
Hunt's show she just lied about her
right on-air telecon Joe Biden
references his relationships with two
former Republican colleagues at an event
in New York City the only problem they
were both segregationists they're not
Republicans they are Democrats they're
definitely Democrats anytime that you
have a party behaving in a sustained way
in a in a bad way on race relations you
can bet that it's the Democrat Party
this has been true since the 19th
century and it remains true today they
are not the party of racial harmony that
they they have never been that party
even when they say that they were the
party of the Civil Rights Act in the
1960s first of all there have been
something like nine civil rights acts
they were all pushed by Republicans
except for this one which was pushed by
a Democrat president and yet it was only
pushed through the LBJ Civil Rights Act
it was only pushed through because of
Republicans the Democrats largely voted
against it and Republicans largely voted
for it still all of that is forgotten
all of that is almost besides the point
the point is what this attack says about
2020 and the toughest one came from Cory
Booker Cory Booker said quote you don't
joke about calling black men boys men
like James O Eastland use words like
that and the racist policies that
accompanied them to perpetuate white
supremacy and strip black Americans of
our very humanity Vice President Biden's
relationships with proud segregationists
are not the model for how we make
America a safer and more inclusive place
for black people and for everyone so he
then went on and said Joe Biden needs to
apologize me this is very hard he's he's
lumping Biden in he's saying Biden's
joke itself was racist
talking about how he didn't call him
way but they called him son and that he
piled around he was working with people
who were white supremacists and he had
those relationships and that's a
terrible thing when cory booker asked
joe biden to apologize for this this was
the straw that broke the camel's back
and joe biden pushed back very hard on
it here is college eyes for what cory
should apologize he knows better there's
not a racist bone in my body i've been
involved in civil rights my whole career
period period period of course joe
biden's right here he doesn't need to
apologize for this i mean politically he
may have to they're trying to back him
into a corner that he does but just as a
matter of morality matter of what he
actually said he has no moral obligation
to apologize
this is totally contrived political
theater except it does serve a purpose
in this campaign and in the light of how
the democrat party is dealing with
politics on a national level we'll get
to that in a second but first admit it
admit it you think that cybercrime is
something that happens to other people i
know you think this cuz i used to think
this too you think nobody wants your
data right they're gonna get everybody
else's data they're gonna steal
everybody others everybody else's photos
and passwords and credit card details
that's what hackers are going for but
not yours right well you would be wrong
stealing data from unsuspecting people
on public Wi-Fi you know the sort of
Wi-Fi that you use all the time is one
of the simplest and cheapest ways for
hackers to make money when you leave
your internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your passwords
and credit card numbers on a huge
billboard for the rest of the world to
see and and think to I mean the
financial stuff is really important
think about you you have celebrities all
the time get their photos hacked it just
happened I think to Bella Thorne right
you think about what you've got on your
computer think about what you've got
some photos maybe think about maybe some
websites that you visit that you don't
want people to see some pretty weird
websites you know what I'm talking about
I'm talking about the Daily wire there
are a lot of things on there you don't
want people to get to protect myself
from cyber criminals I use Express VPN
it secures and anonymizes your internet
browsing encrypt your data hide your
public IP address got easy to use
turning it on takes only one click using
expressvpn you can safely browse on
public Wi-Fi without being snooped on
it's fabulous and that is all for less
than seven bucks per month absolutely
fabulous it's the number one rated VPN
service by TechRadar comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee to protect your
online activity today find out how you
get three months free go to expressvpn
comm / michael expr ESS VPN comm /
michael for three months free with a
one-year package expressvpn comm /
michael to learn more you won't regret
it so this is obviously a totally
contrived political attack one thing
that it does show and one way that I
think it's pretty effective is sure
nobody thinks the Joe Biden is some anti
black bigot but it does remind people
that Joe Biden is very old he's so old
in fact that he served in the US Senate
with pro segregation senators when
segregation was still a thing when
segregation was still a hot political
issue so I think that's pretty good
because he is a little past his sell-by
date he's not a bigot and the story
matters because what it shows is not the
Democrats view on race or the Democrats
view on reparations or the Democrats
view on segregation it shows the
Democrats view on civility what people
are saying what the question the Cory
Booker and other people are bringing up
is not is Joe Biden a segregationist
it's was Joe Biden right to be civil to
segregationists is it right when there
are battles over segregation some awful
political issue is it right to be people
to be civil rather with the people that
you disagree with of course it is of
course Joe Biden was right to be civil
with segregationists yes we should be
civil with the people that we disagree
with politically that is the only way a
democratic republic can survive this
used to be a totally uncontroversial
opinion this was not a left or right
idea now it's become a right wing idea
the left says you can't be civil with
people that you disagree with well but
what what about a terrible awful issue
like segregation there's no
defense of segregation why would you be
civil with those people because a
republic such as ours self government
requires civility requires that we
understand one another it requires that
we persuade one another it requires that
we not just scream and shout and insult
one another and here's an example of
this today forget segregation today half
of all politicians in this country
support abortion they support killing
innocent babies in the womb and
disproportionately black babies since
we're talking about race they're talking
about killing babies we don't just
randomly start punching them on the
floor of the US Congress
we don't just shriek we don't refuse to
speak with people who support abortion
even though abortion is worse than
segregation segregation was terrible
murdering babies is worse murder is
worse than other forms of oppression as
you are totally robbing someone of their
life not just their liberty not just
their ability to pursue happiness and
property you're killing a baby before
the baby is even born that is worse and
yet we're civil with pro-abortion people
why because that's the only way that
we're gonna move the issue that's the
way the pro-life has been able to win so
many battles over the last four decades
five decades but the left can't be civil
don't take my word for it here's Hillary
Clinton explaining why the left won't be
civil anymore you cannot be civil with a
political party that wants to destroy
what you stand for what you care about
that's why I believe if we are fortunate
enough to win back the house and/or the
Senate that's when civility can start
again but until then the only thing that
the Republicans seem to recognize and
respect is strength you can't be civil
with people who oppose everything you
stand for that's that's her theory then
who are you supposed to be civil with if
you don't have to be civil with the
people who disagree with you then what's
the point of civility of course you're
civil with the people who agree with you
you you're not just civil with them you
embrace them you celebrate them the year
they're on your team the
only purpose of civility in politics is
to be civil to the people that you
disagree with but Hillary doesn't grant
that people who disagree with her have
any legitimacy have any right to speak
have any right to vote they're
deplorable they're irredeemable they're
they're the worst kind of people in this
country they shouldn't have a voice they
shouldn't be able to elect a president
guess what happened by the way when she
said that those very people made sure
that she never came within stone's throw
of the White House again it's the same
thing with free speech people say we can
protect free speech but we can't protect
hate speech the whole purpose of the
First Amendment is to protect hate
speech so-called what is hate speech I
don't know
good luck defining it who defines what's
hateful something that's hateful to one
person is maybe not hateful to somebody
else the purpose of the First Amendment
is to defend unpopular speech speech
that if popular speech is already going
to be protected by the mob because
everyone likes it the only reason to do
it the only reason to have civility is
to be civil with the people that you
disagree with what does this look like
it's not just Hillary Clinton is saying
this current elected Democrats Maxine
Waters very prominent Democrat
congresswoman is coming out and showing
you what it looks like when you stop
being civil to your political opponents
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what it looks like you get in
their face you go to where they sleep
you go to where their children sleep you
scream you physically intimidate them
that's what they want to do I mean that
is a recipe to get rid of self
government you cannot have a democratic
republic very long if you keep that up
you're going to have to impose more
order from the top down if you cannot I
mean this is this is the deal that we've
made with self-government and with a
democratic republic we say we we're
going to have political freedom we're
going to run our own country we the
people we can only do that if we
discipline ourselves if we are mature if
we educate ourselves about what the
political issues are and we educate
ourselves about how we're supposed to
behave and if we can be civil and if we
can deal with people that we disagree
with that's the only way we can do it if
we can't do that we will lose
self-government we will lose political
freedom because we have to you can't
that the country must have order order
will reassert itself it will either
assert itself from the bottom up from
people who are disciplined and educated
and serious people who are worthy of
freedom
or it will be imposed on us from the top
down but we will not have anarchy it's
never happened and it's never going to
happen and this is the very risky gamble
that Democrats are trying to foist on us
right now
so the the Joe Biden issue is a really
important one not because of those
stupid race stuff but because Joe Biden
represents the old school of Democrats
who say I hate Republicans they're awful
they're racist they're bigots they're
terrible but I'll be civil with them or
in the case of Joe Biden I guess I hate
other Democrats who are racist and
bigoted and awful but I can be civil
with them that's the old school and the
new school sing don't be civil don't be
civil at all ruin them get physically
violent go to their houses that's the
debate we'll see in this 2020 race which
side of that is going to win before we
get to more race hustling which happened
on Capitol Hill yesterday support for
the Michael Nolt show comes from our
friends at rocket mortgage by Quicken
Loans finding the right house is not
easy let me tell you I've been looking
at house
all over la the whole process is
impossible and it's awful and it's
designed to just drive you completely
crazy rocket mortgages are doing more to
help you understand the home buying
process so you can get exactly what you
need because it's not just a mortgage
it's your mortgage and they have found a
better way these guys are just terrific
they don't make your life too
complicated they really simplify things
their team of mortgage experts is
obsessed with finding a better way
that's why their number one goal is to
make the home buying process smoother
for you
rocket mortgages there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way
they have already helped millions of
Americans achieve their dreams of home
ownership it's worked before let them
work to help you when you're ready to
make the purchase of the home of your
dream when you work with them you get
more than just a loan because rocket
more you're just more than just a lender
get started online right now go to
rocket mortgage.com slash Knolls k nowl
es don't make an already complicated
process more complicated for yourself
level rocket mortgage help you rocket
mortgage Equal Housing lender license in
all 50 states n MLS consumer access at
Oregon umber 30 30 rocket organs by
Quicken Loans push button what happens
get mortgage speaking of the race
hustling that we're seeing in the
Democrat Party sparks were flying
yesterday during this absolute exercise
in national idiocy where we have so few
problems in this country unemployment of
record loads the economy going
gangbusters everybody living in relative
luxury historically speaking that we've
got to dig up slavery 150 years ago and
argue over reparations so that the
great-great great-great grandchildren of
slaves but maybe also slave owners can
get some reparations from I don't know
modern American immigrants who had
nothing to do with slavery and we're
gonna have to figure out who's exactly
the right percentage of victim and
figure out who's going to get what
amount of money which will accomplish
absolutely nothing in this melee of
idiocy and victimhood the NFL star
Burgess Burgess Owens showed up and he
just gave a total smackdown of the whole
premise of the hearing here is I'm going
to talk about some ideologies when I
talk about it when I talk about people
people change I used to be a Democrat
until I did my history and found out the
the misery that that party brought to my
race I do not believe in reparation
because what reparation does it points
to a certain race a certain color and
and it points them as evil and points
the other race my race is one that has
not only becomes racist but the dead but
also beggars I do believe in restitution
let's point to the party that was that
was part of slavery KKK Jim Crow that
has killed over 40% of our black babies
20 million of them state of California
70 75 percent of our black boys cannot
pass 10 and reading writing test a
democratic state so yes let's play rest
rest
restoration rest play rest restitution
how about a Democratic Party pay for all
the misery brought in my race and those
after after we learn our history decide
to stay there they they should pay also
they're complicit in every white
American Republican or Democrat that
feels guilty because of your white skin
you should need to pony up also that
wouldn't get past this reparation to
recognize that this country is giving us
greatness I love this idea I mean he
really just goes for the jugular so the
left and the Democrats they want to say
slavery it's the the original sin of
America and it's all of Americans in all
of white America like well no actually
to be specific it's Democrats and the
Republican Party was founded to a post
slavery and then the founding of the
Republican Party led to a civil war
where 600,000 to 750,000 Americans died
to end slavery it's actually a Democrat
problem and then the issues of the KKK
the Jim Crow laws segregation lynchings
that also was not just an American
problem it was specifically a Democrat
problem that KKK was the terrorist wing
of the Democrat Party Burgess Owens
calling them out for that entirely so
that was very enjoyable I don't know
what it does to the debate on
reparations but it was very fun to watch
the case for reparations broadly I think
one thing he really expressed well is
that it's very disrespectful
the premise of reparations in 2019 is
that blacks need handouts from whites
because there's no other way that they
could succeed and you look at that guy
Burgess Owens and you say well he
succeeded pretty well is a pretty sharp
guy at an incredible athletic career now
he's got a great career and in
commentary and politics does Burgess
Owens get reparations is some poor white
guy in Appalachia supposed to pay
Burgess Owens how about is some poor
white guy in Appalachia who may be
descended from slave owners or maybe
didn't is he supposed to pay jay-z and
Beyonce reparations for slavery
so you gonna pay Barack Obama
reparations for slavery present former
President of the United States half
black half white actually not descended
from black slaves descended from African
African immigrant or an app that
actually just an African national who
happened to have been in America you
know we talked yesterday about how the
first formally recognized American slave
owner of of an arbitrary arbitrary
declared slave for life was a black guy
does that guy's ancestors do they get
reparations let's say as is the case for
most black Americans that they have some
white ancestry maybe a white slave-owner
ancestry do they get reparations how
white is too white how black is black
are we going to resurrect the racist
one-drop rule to say if you have one
drop of black blood then you are black
that makes you essentially racially
black and it defines you and entitles
you to some reparations one of the
reasons there are many reasons that
reparations are totally impracticable in
2019 but one of them were the most
offensive one is that it is a racially
essentialist idea that just does not
jibe with reality it doesn't jive with
150 years of American history and
immigration and and descent but just
even my side and I'm descended from
Italians Irish Welsh English all the
Sicilians all these sorts of people
which is me for mixed-race people are
they black are they white which ways out
the other one doesn't make a lot of
sense and Burgess Owens showed some of
that absurdity but the entire
reparations debate yesterday was a
sideshow and it was all just part of the
broader absurd clown show which is the
20/20 Democrat presidential primary
bad news came out for Joe Biden
yesterday beyond the race stuff the
mainstream media are finally asking
questions about his shady deals with his
son in Ukraine and in China so while Joe
Biden was chief diplomat was vice
president he was he was leading American
negotiations in the Ukraine and in China
hunter Biden his son was getting shady
deals he got I think a billion dollars
or more of funding out of China for a
company called Rosemont that he was
working with and in the Ukraine he was
able to get a I think fifty five
thousand dollar per month retainer when
he was on the board of a company called
burries Mahal dings this was WOW Biden
was there and negotiating with Ukraine
Biden as the chief diplomat for Ukraine
was threatening to withhold American aid
to the Ukraine if the Ukraine didn't
fire a prosecutor looking into his son's
shady business dealings it was pretty
pretty rough and we've been talking
about this for months on the show
finally the mainstream media started
asking the questions just within the
last two days was hunter Biden profiting
off his dad's work as vice president and
did Jill Biden allow it we're talking
about millions of dollars in at least
two countries
mr. vice president Tom yamas with ABC
News how you doing got a quick question
for you it's a question we tried to ask
repeatedly can we ask you about Ukraine
and China but kept getting blocked
questions about foreign deals his son
Hunter Biden pursued my father Joe Biden
in countries with Joe Biden who's
working as America's top diplomat mr.
vice president's your take on that was
there a conflict of interest there was
there a clear conflict of interest hey
look we've got journalists in the
mainstream media finally this is I know
it's a cold and chilly day in hell and
pigs are flying all over the world
because a mainstream Network journalist
is asking tough questions of Joe Biden
questions that we've been asking on this
show for months so why are they asking
it now why what changed
I mean we've known this story for a long
time obviously Joe Biden is ducking the
question because he knows he's guilty as
sin here he later gave a statement or
his campaign gave a statement that said
that if he were elected president he
would empower White House Ethics lawyers
to monitor these sorts of activities
that he engaged so he's basically
admitting guilt here he's admitting he
acted inappropriately and let his son
peddle his influence to make a lot of
money out of both of those countries
still looks like he's dodging now
finally June 20th the mainstream media
will ask the question why the reason is
because back then months ago when this
came up the mainstream media were
backing Joe Biden as the leading
candidate for president now it seems
they're moving toward another candidate
and so they're willing to ditch Joe
Biden who's that other candidate
according to a June Wall Street Journal
NBC News poll Liz Warren is surging this
poll looked a Democrat primary voters
who were enthusiastic or comfortable
with candidates so back in March they
said who are your most comfortable
candidates who are you most excited for
Joe Biden then got 77% support now a few
months later down to 66% he's lost 11
percentage points Bernie Sanders down
from 62% in March now he's at 56% in
June Liz Warren surging she had 57
percent in March she's now up to 64
percent so she made a significant gain
seven percentage points and she's moving
in the right direction so what Democrats
and the media are saying now is that Liz
Warren might be a compromise candidate
she's got all those left-wing bona fides
and she's sort of acceptable she's
really annoying and unpleasant but she's
not detestable she's not that old she's
a woman she's very white but she
pretends to be Native American so she
checks a few intersectional boxes
because the Pocahontas thing has been
around for so long there's I guess a
chance she can survive it she's never
come up with a good answer on it but
more importantly all the other
candidates have proven themselves really
weak Joe Biden had his best day
basically on his first day of his
campaign and he's been tanking they call
him creepy they call him old they call
him corrupt they now call him racist
they call him too conservative so he's
having a tough time other candidates who
we thought would be good like
Kamala Harris have just proven
themselves mostly incompetent other
candidates Cory Booker kind of a joke
Pete Budaj edge is a fairly talented
candidate but he's the very young mayor
of a very small town so how serious is
he gonna be I'm not quite sure he's also
a white guy
so Liz Warren is starting to define
herself as possibly a compromise
candidate she might have a moment to
make a comeback here and that is really
that's the worst news of all for Joe
Biden because if the media do get behind
her he doesn't have a chance we have got
to get to the mailbag but first I've got
important news today is the last day for
exclusive presale tickets s to our
backstage live show taking it on the
road
August 21st at the terrorist theater in
Long Beach California ben shapiro de la
wire god-king jeremy boring the Lord of
the multiverse Andrew Klavan and little
old me most importantly of all will be
on stage discussing the winners and
losers of politics and pop culture and
doing our best to answer your burning
questions from the audience
tickets go on sale to the public this
Friday but only daily wire subscribers
get presale tickets s today there are
only 300 VIP tickets available which
include premium seating photos and meet
and greets with each of us and a gift
from Ben Shapiro himself and more I fear
what that is that gonna be like Ben
beheads me or something live that no
that would be a gift for Ben Shapiro
himself so anyway it's gonna be a lot of
fun head over to daily wire comm slash
backstage get your tickets today come
join us for one absolutely fabulous
night it's gonna be a lot of fun you
know you get everything else at the
Daily wire - you got to go over there
because they're gonna kick us off of
social media pretty soon so go to daily
wire we'll be right back with the
mailbag
I'm gonna fly through these questions
today I'm gonna get to all of them maybe
we'll see from anonymous hi Michael of
all the books adapted into Hollywood
movies what is one story yet to be
faithfully adapted to the big screen
that needs to be there have been a lot
of bad movies out of books a lot of
books I don't read a ton of fiction
anyway so I don't totally care except
for one book that I really want to see
made into a movie a confederacy of
dunces by John Kennedy Toole this is a
book that was published posthumously by
this guy who killed himself the book was
found by his mother I think it ended up
getting published and then it ended up
winning the Pulitzer Prize for fiction
in 1981 and this book if you haven't
read it gave America one of the great
characters of its literature which is
Ignatius J Reilly this big fat weird
lazy lay about medieval list guy it's
just what I can't describe what a great
character he is and all of the
adventures that he has living with his
mother wandering around New Orleans
getting a job and trying to it's just
he's just a fabulous character I think
it would be a great movie they've never
made one before they're always been
rumors that they're gonna they're gonna
make one but that's one if I had any
clout in Hollywood which I don't if I
were able to you know even walk down the
street in Hollywood without people
throwing Rotten Tomatoes at me for my
politics that would be one book that I
try to make into a movie for max hey
Michael I'm a Catholic and therefore
believe marriage is between one man and
one woman in the church do you think the
government should get out of marriage
entirely and do you think a Christian
can hold this position no I don't I
think it's I don't think the government
can get out of marriage I think this is
a total cop-out I know probably the
majority of conservatives these days say
that they just want the government
completely out of marriage this has
always been a sort of libertarian
position or it's been at least viewed as
a libertarian position I think it's
completely incoherent it doesn't make
any sense the government if the
government has an interest
in any aspect of your life it has an
interest in marriage marriage is the
essential building block of society and
it always has been why does the
government have an interest in marriage
well if the government has an interest
in any aspect of society which obviously
it does it has an interest in marriage
also because of children the government
does have an interest in children the
government has an interest in what you
can do to your children if you abuse
your children the government can come in
and take them away
well how are children raised they're
raised within the context of the family
and the essence of the family is
marriage
how about adoption the government has
plenty of regulations surrounding
adoption as well it should well rules
about adoption ultimately come down to
marriage now we have loosened laws about
adoption in recent years so single
people can adopt gay couples can adopt
there all of these question even if you
support those policies those questions
still surround marriage either because
they're saying we're gonna change the
definition of marriage or we're gonna
change the importance of marriage but
nevertheless the government is
interacting with that I think the the
lie that some people who don't want to
have to deal with the difficult question
of what marriage is who don't want to
offend people and say marriage obviously
involves sexual difference it involves
men and women is they say well listen
I've got the neutral position I'm gonna
get the government out of marriage
entirely well that is a position to say
that the government is getting out of
marriages to say that the government
does not view does not have a definition
of marriage or rather that the guttin
obviously the government does have a
definition of marriage by saying that
monogamous same-sex couples can now be
marriage but words need to have meaning
the the marriage debate was totally lost
by conservatives because we allowed the
left to define it in terms of rights do
gay people have the right to get married
gay people have always had the right to
get married the question is what is
marriage and for all of human history
virtually everywhere certainly
throughout the West marriage has been
the union of husbands and wives sexual
difference has been
essential to marriage and then about
five minutes ago the left decided that
sexual difference had nothing to do with
marriage love is love love wins there
all sorts of love
I've loved with my brother I've loved
with my friends I've loved with my
parents I've loved with my country I
love is not just love there are lots of
different kinds of love
I've loved with my girlfriend but my
girlfriend oh shoot I hope my wife isn't
watching now no I mean before I was
married I have you know you love your
girlfriend but then the love you have
with your fiance is a little different
that's a different union the love you
have with your wife is different than
the love you have with your fiance and
marriage has a meaning and the
government establishes at least at a
very basic level establishes the very
definitions that we're working with we
all need to be on the same page for
certain institutions and one of those
the bedrock one of those is marriage we
need a definition of marriage
conservatives basically are surrendering
that to the left I think because we just
don't want to have to deal with an issue
that in the popular culture at least has
been lost but it doesn't change the fact
marriage is between a man and a woman no
amount of social engineering is going to
change that and it's I think it's
ultimately an act of political cowardice
for us to back away and say we don't we
don't have anything to do with that we
don't want to fight that fight anymore
from David greetings to Michel Noel's or
Eric sois well well it's not an
either/or Eric's well well is all of us
in the talk about race the left
usually asserts that racism is only
possible when power and privilege are a
factor word play aside is bigotry not
only logically wrong but morally wrong
if no corruption and/or violence takes
place so there are two parts of this
question one is what is racism so with
the what is racism racism obviously is
an antagonism or a discrimination
against another person based on feelings
of racial superiority or racial
inferiority that is racism the left is
redefining racism because they always
want to redefine words because that's
how you control the culture and the
politics and the way they're redefining
racism is to say sure racism is
hostility antagonism discrimination on
the basis of race
but only if your the more powerful race
never if you're the less powerful race
and we're gonna define more powerful
races white and less powerful race as
black or Hispanic or Native American and
therefore only whites can be racist
they just redefine the word racism to
mean that only white people can be
racist but that's absurd
I mean that's you're just changing the
definition of the word to something that
it is not and on the question of how
wrong bigotry is racial bigotry is wrong
because it is an affront to human
dignity that's why that's that's better
that's why racism is wrong and the left
is trying to have its cake and eat it
too they're trying to agree with that
point and then say except it's not wrong
if you're racist against whites it's
just wrong if you have an antagonism or
you discriminate against another person
because of feelings of racial
superiority or inferiority whether it's
against whites or blacks or Hispanics or
whatever that is racism and you're
guilty of it and that is an affront to
human dignity from anonymous Michael I
am a student entering my first year of
college do you have any date ideas for a
poor college student
hashtag came for been subscribed for
Michael well speaking of how the left
gets things exactly backwards I got to
tell you back in my a theistic reckless
irresponsible days when I when I was
single and in college I too engaged in I
guess what you would call the backwards
culture of the left which is that at
least when I was there the dominant kind
of culture was not dating it wasn't
courtship it wasn't dating for marriage
it was the hook-up culture and I think
that's still the dominant culture on
campus so instead of taking a girl out
on a date and then going back and
hooking up it was actually the opposite
you did see a girl at a party or a bar
and you'd go hook up and and you'd go
back to your room and then you do this
like five or six times and then maybe
eventually you'd go on a date too so I
really I'm not the best person to ask
for advice here because I was engaged in
this totally inverted culture as well
but the nice thing about college is
everyone has pretty low expectations
because everyone's broke so I you just
you don't need to worry about that
College offers so many
opportunities to have fun for not all
that much money so I don't know take a
girl anything from a dorm party to a
cheap restaurant or a cheap college bar
to a walk in the park or walk around
campus you you can really get away with
just about anything because the
expectations are low once you get out
into the real world and start making
money the expectations for dates become
much much more expensive so enjoy it
while you can you can't go wrong just be
just be a good guy be interested in the
girl find a girl that you like and don't
try to be a jerk about it don't try to
play a game don't try to be something
that you're not be confident go pursue
the girl gets the girl from Benjamin
Michael last week you had a very
insightful episode of at pride and how
pride is the queen of all sins I
generally agree but it got me wondering
if there is a distinct difference
between having pride and being proud of
accomplishments for example should I be
proud of getting good grades in school
or successfully overcoming some
challenge thanks Ben I was wondering
about this this question of pride and
personal accomplishment or national
pride for instance I'm proud of my
country I think pride is wrong in both
cases still so the tougher one is pride
in accomplishments because let's say you
you write a really good blank book you
know and you're really proud of how
successful it was or you do a really
good podcast or you do well on a test or
whatever you naturally feel a temptation
to pride to take to claim total
responsibility for that but actually the
traditional response to this is that you
should give all glory to God and that's
not just a soft words or something
that's not just some sentimentality
that's not just pretending you really do
give glory to God why because the
circumstances of your life were given to
you you didn't earn them you were born
into a certain family born into the
United States born into privilege I mean
when you think about the privileges that
you had in it from a position of
gratitude rather than a position of
guilt or envy I think it's actually a
good way to think about your life even
your own intelligence you didn't earn
your own intelligence you have your own
intelligence your work ethic is a
product in part of your culture and
your will and a will that you were
turning toward the good which is
something outside of you so when it
comes to your own accomplishments I give
it up to God give glory to God this is
something that you are doing the
accomplishment not just for yourself or
for your own vain glory but for the
glory of God for the good and so that's
how I would deal with personal
accomplishments as for national pride I
don't think that you actually take pride
in your country in the way that we talk
about Pride Month or pride is the queen
of all sin I think what you have is
really a form of piety for your country
it's a form of piety like the respect
for your father and mother like respect
for your family your parents your
ancestors things that came before you
it's a question of love and allegiance
rather than pride as well and I I wanna
i don't really see people like spiking
the football too much and saying yeah
woohoo america it's it's all because of
how great I am and how great no it's
actually a form of gratitude and respect
for things that actually you did not do
it's not really a form of pride and and
because pride essentially is just
exaggerating one's own excellence from
Britney Michael how can conservatives
make nuanced and complex issues such as
taxation health care and immigration
reform more relatable to college
students I'm 30 years old and a lifelong
conservative but I wasn't able to truly
relate to these issues until I was in
the workforce myself and saw how the
real world worked this is why I think
it's much easier for these young
students to be outspoken on social
issues such as gay marriage and hate
speech and ignore everything else thank
you yeah I think this is true in part
obviously the finer points of tax policy
are a lot more boring than talking about
abortion or something but that's because
the only thing that actually matters or
social issues and everything else is
just being counting including the finer
points of health care policy and tax
policy I don't actually care that much
about taxes I like lower taxes because I
like keeping more of my property and I
think it's more moral and I like having
more liberty but I don't really care
what I care about or the foundations of
those issues
what I care about or what or underneath
tax policy was underneath health care
policy and I think sometimes
conservatives especially in that 1980s
policy wonk mold they get a little too
focused on the particulars of policy but
you're not gonna win anybody by being
the most efficient bureaucrat or
technocrat that's not compelling not for
college students and not for voters more
generally the left focuses on social
issues because they work because they're
compelling because they actually stir
people's souls we're not just here
trying to rearrange certain aspects of
the federal bureaucracy to make life a
little more efficient we're talking
about things that matter why do you get
to keep your money why should we be in
control of our own health care and be
able to choose our own doctors what does
that say about us and our freedom in our
national political traditions and the
good that it does for us and the whole
rest of the world that's what I would
focus on and I wouldn't cede the
question of so-called social issues to
the left the great example of this is
abortion abortion was winning at the
time that roe v wade was decided and
since then public opinion has moved
steadily in our direction because the
arguments for abortion cannot subsist
Ain themselves in the light of truth and
in the light of sonograms and in the
light of science and the arguments that
we're making for it so I would even when
you're making tax arguments even when
you're making healthcare arguments I
would make them from a cultural from a
social from a moral standpoint it's you
know the left so just on taxes the left
says that if you want to keep your own
money you're greedy but if you want to
steal somebody else's money and take it
for yourself and give it to everybody
else then you're compassionate that's of
course the opposite the opposite is is
true if I want to keep my own money
that's my money and then I can give it
out in charity and if you want to steal
my money you're envious oh you're greedy
that's wrong that's immoral and we
should speak in those terms and I think
we'll win and I think we are winning on
that all right that's our show come back
on Monday we'll have a lot more I'm
gonna be up in Santa Barbara speaking to
the young America's Foundation over the
weekend go ahead in over to the reagan
ranch should be a lot of fun maybe
you'll be able to catch that on live
stream otherwise I'll see you next week
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today the Democrats conducted a hearing
yesterday on reparations but I think
there are a lot of very serious problems
with the reparations idea namely it's
immoral and extremely impractical so
we'll talk about that today also amazing
advancements in medical technology are
continuing to make abortion more and
more obsolete though pro-abortion people
of course haven't noticed that yet so
we'll talk about that and I'll answer
your emails today over on the Matt Walsh
show